they're in the way five years ago
with Philadelphia Jordan with a Miss on
a three inside the card away yo biggie
strong puts it on the floor really well
tough to guard oh yeah beautiful the
beaters Davis averaged 28 points and 11
rebounds a season ago Martin womp it up
capela took care of it from there it's
on the West Bank
he was very happy about coming home
corner three is good by PJ Tucker was a
game best plus 23 didn't shoot it well
just one of seven for three but did have
ten rebounds and fella able to tap it up
and has saved it falling out of bounds
after the collision with Harrell hard
back to Clinton oh look
[Applause]
pardon all 150 passed there was
which comes off the pick-and-roll and he
sees the lane the pass right there and
so James could have just given him a
normal pass but he likes to raise the
the difficulty mates love him regardless
of what rajon rondo says about it harden
to capela boards two assists having a
great start to the season is sabonis and
the Rockets beat them at their own game
problem it's sort of been plug and play
for them and one of their starters
positions in using Torrey Craig now it's
hurting Gomes and the alley open capela
lays it up it in at the alley-oop um on
the previous trip as Clint just goes out
of there and the help defender had to
choose still shoot the three offensive
rebound mark
alright the kick of the corner to Tucker
another quarter three for PJ Tucker the
Rockets offense is very potent there's
the LOB hard a long pass after the
initial foul by Sexton and capela dunks
it down with James with the key Malaysia
one there's a good look at James to
Clint over the top nice screen here by
Eric Gordon to get Bart turns the corner
wide open Gordon in the corner
that's number four for Eric Gordon and
the Rockets driving it anytime to win
right now art in the corner Tucker with
a 3-2 capella the Rockets are off to a
great start there check out the enemy
you James to capella you've heard it
before capella way above the rim he
moves it across there's hardly for the
name way Chris will talk it over
beautiful pass from Harden and an a does
the rest not a five on the shot clock
here's harden on the drive Game seven
and how do you stop this I hit you with
the heads he I can hit the layup dunk
over you it's kind of snowballs
everybody loses their garden there's a
double-team on
Tan's had no chance there's a guy who's
the gun for hire in the corner PJ Tucker
people way the love game that's so
effective between he and James Harden
great dish underneath capella sit in
plus a foul he feels like his guy is
hung up rotation a little bit late and
this is where capella how about that
pass right between the defenders is
there to receive the ball and flush and
bottom half of the circle couldn't get
it there counselor
capella and stride backs the vacant
khattala
is there once again they're going to him
a lot
[Music]
PJ Tucker
black shuttle nezzie fix it play that's
the second block shot tonight
Gary Clark that leads to between the
legs now no look right backwards to Gary
Clark who says you know what that's a
great pass I'm gonna give you this
finally somebody got it right capela
beats everybody down the floor again
yeah nice pass we talk all the time
about how James Harden is the best pass
ahead passer in the NBA thank you two
points James Harden's to pass ahead pass
and the Rockets lead by eight you were
really good develop that's now 12 points
per 20 C Raptors waiting for it
on the fastbreak gets around see ocular
passes
we're reading be been write in for Clint
capela as he gets it done four points
and eight rebounds
James Harden
against rain hits it out that's Tucker
spot tonight crews another ones over to
help good double team by Houston
[Music]
[Applause]
he's going off rockets outscoring
Orlando 20 there's good defense by
Houston creates a turnover
three-on-two fast-break
[Music]
here's James Ark see how he looks away
yeah and actually cleaver went home
three he's another European basketball
player there's the Mavericks who trying
to find because they love the skill
level 611
and Aaron Gordon hints again this
business the playoff run but I always
say one correction I would have to make
enough from her but to the team the
beautiful double pump dunk right there
by capella does that trust has to come
first to get wins the game we play next
is the only one that counts we think
that they wanted haven't gone back to
that as much second half Hospital has
checked back here here fellas lays it in
there we go that pick-and-roll so hard
to stop specially when you're not
communicating to fit the game
Martin and Batum who was drafted by the
rocket throws it a cappella and this
time he's able to get to an income NBA
season well you bastard you were
sizzling on that one oh yeah three gives
it up to James James giving it back -
did you see that
picked off the sinner he was trying to
get down the court to guard Ferengi
watching us boy that's just beautiful
yeah and he knew see how he's looking
off he's looking the other way
so the defenders don't think that he
sees freak while he's yelling at ed
Malloy here comes Harden the other way
Martin throws it up capela Looney picks
up harden on the switch all right throws
it up eight straight points by the
Rockets gnarly yeah cuz he's a good
penetrator good hustler yes he is
I'm the one draft choice that's gonna be
two and one Jackson so I'm coming
couldn't do anything about it
euro-step watch this one too he steps
around the defender very nice cp3 was
injured Eric Gordon was out for one
capella again
you take good shots they play fast that
corner three therefore John Collins he's
been very good at that this time it's
harden to capela our first timeout Clint
capela is the Rockets leading scorer
he's got sick renown capella with the
rebound and it beats everybody down to
the hoop and harm what a sequence
Capella's celebration after the showers
special but I pass inside block by
capella the average is about two-a-days
[Applause]
Martin boot camp out with Beasley sets
up PJ Tucker from the way
James organized between the legs to
capella Showtime and here's James's past
the acapellas running right to the
rhythm so James goes through his own
five hole a nice finish there for
capella go through going against shuttle
Frenchman Rudy Gobert shot clock me down
a toy
[Music]
[Applause]
Your Honor in the game his mates the
floor to get measles and others it going
on penetrate draw the defense rockets
we're trying to do the first road team
to win serious some heart and just like
that
the Rockets have chiseled into a
one-time 15-point lead for Golden State
harden in Sampson to begin it hug has
been terrific five of seven to three
good that he's been spectacular from
that corner three that's his third made
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content